i see this question all the time
jan asked us this question
and it was uh how to encourage people
who don't exercise to start exercising
and maintain it you know what is the
approach to
kind of spurring someone to engage with
exercise whether it's walking running
cycling or strength training
a kind of broad summary like a very
basic overview of self-determination
theory is that
people generally have this kind of
inherent
intrinsic drive toward
growth and learning and self-improvement
and self-actualization we do have this
kind of drive to learn new things and
acquire new skills and get better and
better and better
that that is kind of written in our code
but in order for us to really strive
toward goals and
reach toward growth and self-improvement
and self-actualization
we need some basic psychological needs
to be met in order to kind of set the
foundation for that and to really set us
up for success and within this theory
the three main pillars are relatedness
competence and autonomy
so in order for us to start really
making these big goal related strides
towards something uh that's going to be
good for us you know some kind of
self-improvement or self you know growth
or actualization relatedness refers to
the fact that we want to feel part of
something we want to feel tapped into a
community we want to feel like this
means something outside of just our
personal experience with it
competence of course means that we have
self-efficacy we feel like we're
actually capable of doing what we're
setting out to do and autonomy means
that we
we have some degree of control over it
we we have the ability to kind of uh set
the trajectory that we're on
and kind of set our own short and
intermediate term goals and determine
how we go about goal striving not just
following instructions so what i would
encourage people oh and i should mention
that one of the huge elements of
self-determination theory is the idea of
motivation and more specifically that
there are distinct types of motivation
that fall on a spectrum
so if you
dig into the self-determination theory
literature you'll actually see figures
that show this spectrum or this
continuum of motivation and on one end
it starts with a motivation so just
complete lack of motivation which is
obviously one end of of the spectrum
kind of the most extreme end
on the other end of the spectrum is
intrinsic motivation so so motivation
that is derived from within uh and then
kind of the middle ground you know it's
better than no motivation but not as
powerful not as effective as intrinsic
motivation in the middle there you find
certain forms of extrinsic motivation
and that's really important because when
when i see people trying to encourage
others to adopt exercise and engage with
exercise a lot of times i feel like
they're really
uh
they would be much better off if they
had this theory in mind and what i mean
by that is with relatedness a great
thing you can do to help somebody adopt
exercise is
to
let them know that you are on their team
it's a support thing so it's not like if
you don't exercise you let me down it's
more we're in this together i'm here to
support you you can lean on me and i
also think it's important that you offer
up the
uh the idea that you know you may want
some uh some support
uh when you're
starting this process of adopting
exercise and you might not want it to be
me you might want to start exercise in a
group fitness setting or join a club or
a team or hire a coach or hire a trainer
or
you know any number of ways that you can
have some kind of social group
associated with exercise and the
important thing is if you're really
trying to help someone else don't be
selfish about it and say yeah here's
some relatedness i'm your guy you know
and
your relatedness as it pertains to
exercise is that you rely on me as your
support group
you have to give them the opportunity to
self-select a really effective support
group which can take many different
forms
uh the next thing competence sometimes
i'll see people who say hey you know you
should really be lifting weights and you
should probably be doing it four times a
week and you should probably doing uh
you know a very specific form of
resistance exercise
but they don't give them the tools to
actually feel competent right it's
there a lot of times you see people who
put just kind of shove people into the
deep end and say hey here's a program
it's four days a week half of these are
like olympic lifts or highly skilled
barbell movements anyway good luck and
by the way if you don't adopt this
successfully you kind of suck yeah like
you have to equip people with competence
yeah here here's a program called
starting strength you can learn it from
this book you don't need someone to
teach you and also one of the exercises
is power cleans have fun yeah exactly so
you want to make sure you're fostering
relatedness in a non-selfish way
you want to make sure that you're
fostering competence by either
you know kind of guiding them through it
showing them the ropes equipping them
with resources that really are meeting
them where they're at and not where you
think they ought to be and then the
final thing is autonomy so sometimes
people will say i'm going to provide you
support so there's your relatedness i'm
going to teach you how to do this so
that's competence but also i'm going to
insist that you do everything a very
particular way and what they do there is
they detract from autonomy they don't
say hey there are many ways to engage in
exercise let's explore that entire menu
and you can pick the things that you
like instead it's like hey on tuesdays
we squat and you're squatting with me
and you gotta squat my way and if i like
high bar and you like low bar sorry
you're a high bar squatter you know like
so what what you find is that a lot of
people who have tried this in the past
and failed i think self-determination
theory provides some really clear
examples of why
there is failure there so you you have
to
make sure that someone is able to find a
support group that really resonates and
works for them you have to make sure
that they have opportunities to develop
the competence required to engage and
exercise regularly and you have to offer
them a level of autonomy and
independence so that they can really
start to to kind of foster that
intrinsic motivation but in a lot of
cases you've got people who say no you
have to do it a certain way
you have no autonomy because i give you
your programs and there's no idea of
there's not even a concept of intrinsic
motivation
i'm going to tell you what to do so your
motivation comes from me which isn't
extrinsic and you have absolutely no
autonomy in the process so
my answer is like i said first of all
make sure that you are truly operating
with their best interest in mind and not
yours and then lean on some of these
pillars of self-determination theory so
that you can put them in a position to
succeed to develop that intrinsic
motivation and once someone truly feels
a sense of relatedness and they feel
competent and they feel like they have
autonomy and
they have
that intrinsic motivation because you've
helped them understand
that this is truly in their best
interest i think that's where it really
sticks